Now we're going to take a quick programming quiz on branch coverage.
The quiz is going to involve some Python code that simulates some adders.
Adders are very simple hardware modules that perform addition.
Here I'm just going to draw a 1-bit adder to show you how it works.
The code that you're going to test is going to be a cascading series of 8 of these.
The way the adder works is it takes two inputs, A and B,
and A and B are bits--so they're valued at either 0 or 1,
and in Python we're going to represent the 1 bit as true and the 0 bit as false.
So, we're going to use Boolean logic to implement this, and there's a carry bit coming in.
The output is a single-bit sum of A and B plus a carry bit out.
The function implemented by the adder can be described like this: [S = A ⊕ B ⊕ Cin]
The sum is the A input XORed with the B input XORed with the C input.
To do an XOR on two booleans in Python, we can simply use the not equals operator [!=].
The carry out is going to equal to                         (A · B) +(Cin · (A⊕B)).
And so the "and" and "or" operators in Python are, of course, logical and and or.
What we have here is a couple of boolean equations that together implement a full 1-bit adder.
If we change these adders together, we can build up something extremely exciting
like an actual adder that corresponds to the add instruction
that you would find in an instruction set for a real computer.
Now let's look at the code. Here I have some Python code implementing an 8-bit adder.
What you can see is it takes a0 through a7.
That is to say 8 bits of input that constitute parts of a where a0 is the low order bit,
and a7 is the highest bit.
Then b0 through b7 indicate the bits of the second input
where again B0 is the lowest order bit of B and B7 is the highest.
It takes in an initial carry-in bit.
The chain of logic here is a cascading series of full adders for the individual bits.
As you can see, it's a little bit long.
And so your problem for this API quiz is to come up with a series of call to this 8-bit add function
which get 100% branch coverage.
And let me give you a couple hints.
First of all, the way to approach this is probably to think about how you would test an actual adder.
Most likely, if we're testing an adder--
that is to say let's say this code is part of some sort of a circuit simulation,
and we want to test the validity of our circuit, we'd pass it actual numbers.
How do you pass it actual numbers?
Well, you can write in some little support functions for yourself
that take integers and convert them into the bit format.
That's probably how I would test this, and that's certainly not the only way,
but what you probably don't want to do is treat this as a black box.
What's I'm deliberately doing here is giving you a function
that's going to be a difficult test if you don't understand this logic at all.
What you need to do is think of this as an adder and then it really becomes fairly easier to test.